and linda we're looking at a
portrait of a man who's holding up two
hands into the camera
with question marks on them quite a
fascinating image per se
this is richard there a stanford
professor who
is known for pioneering the use of
lasers
to study chemical processes on the
molecular level
what's the story behind the picture he's
really a character
all his colleagues told me and that's
true he's really a character
and he made his first research
experiment already when he was
three or four you know he gets bunked he
got spanked by his father
and then he was angry and then he
urinated
in his aquarium and all the topical fish
died
and then he gets banked again and you
know
and then he was really impressed what
chemical can do
that you know it was really amazing and
also he told me
to be successful in science you have to
be a constant schizophrenic
you have to believe an idea but also
immediately
you have to question is it really true
does it really work
they also told me nine of ten times we
will fail
and also another wisdom of him you know
as a child you're born with a lot of
curiosity
and wandering and you're always asking
why
so never stop in life don't grow up
always asking why
why don't stop it